foreign
ly one of the most interesting and
weirdest figures in Norse mythology but
this video isn't really about him well
it kind of is but the focus is on his
four children
Loki's children are often considered
monstrous and misunderstood because they
aren't exactly your normal children in
terms of appearance however when you
consider Loki is an eccentric
shape-shifting trickster it starts to
make sense
staying on the topic of monstrous
Bloodlines today's video has been made
possible by bloodline Heroes of lythus
Heroes of lythus is a 3D fantasy based
RPG where you collect Champions and
build your own kingdom by combining
various Bloodlines from races such as
Orcs demons lichens and Dragonborn as
you explore and battle your way through
the world you'll find many different
companions that can be customized and
married off into different Bloodlines
with the ultimate goal of making the
most powerful Offspring to rule your
kingdom the family trees and abilities
will always mean that you receive a
unique outcome until you find a set of
skills that suit you best the
combinations and possibilities are
endless fans of fenrir Might prefer the
the lycanus clan or if you use my link
you'll receive the clan of carg for free
Dragonborn who have the ability to
transform into real dragons maybe scales
and fur aren't your thing in that case
you can try the Folger powerful demigods
with unrivaled AOE abilities MyLink also
gets you an extremely rare
half-dragon-born half demigod air for
free if you'd like to try creating your
own legendary bloodline you can use my
link in the description to try the game
out for free or you can scan the QR code
that's been on the screen this entire
time for signing up you'll also receive
an exclusive starter pack worth twenty
dollars that includes 20 intimacy packs
100
000 gold and 100 diamonds so why not
start your bloodline today
now when I said Loki had four children
that wasn't true there are four
well-known children hell fenrir yorman
Gander and slip near these four and
their distinct appearances have been
somewhat popularized in both the prose
and poetic Eda Loki is married to the
goddess sigin and together they had one
son named narfi or nari the role that
Loki played in the death of Boulder
would see his son pay for his father's
actions Odin had a son named Vali who
was born with only one purpose to avenge
the death of Boulder and to bind and
punish Loki he does this by killing
Loki's son nadafi and using his entrails
to bind him there is no other
significant mention of nadafi he kind of
just exists to pay for the sins of his
father there is a translation that
states Vali was also a son of Loki and
to punish him the I see a transformed
Vali into a wolf who then turned on his
brother nari tearing him to pieces this
translation has been categorized as an
error by many historians as there are
several accounts of Valley as the son of
Odin most of us aren't here for stories
of pornography what about the Monstrous
children Loki may have been married but
he still had children with a giantess
and a horse with the yotan anger border
Loki had three children hell fenrir and
yordmen Gander their mother's name
roughly transl relates to mean one who
brings grief or harm and she was often
associated with anger so given Loki's
mischievous nature these three were
always destined for trouble all three
children were raised in yotenheim away
from the icir when the gods did
eventually learn of their existence and
their connection to Loki they were
prophesized to bring disaster to all
those around them Odin wanting to avoid
this ordered the children were found and
brought before him the decision he came
to was to separate all three children
yorman gandir otherwise known as the
world serpent would be thrown into the
sea hell would be sent to nifleheim
where she would Reign Over the region
also known as hell fenria was to remain
with the god gods in Asgard where they
could watch over him closely
so let's begin with Loki's daughter hell
of the three children she was given the
most responsibility in niflheim she
would have rule over hell which we can
somewhat equate to the underworld by
Odin she was granted authority over the
nine worlds when someone died of
sickness or old age it was hell's
responsibility to collects and house
them we do see hell's name appear in a
number of sagas and poems and it's
almost always relating to somebody's
death as you may expect from a deity or
Spirit associated with the underworld
hell has a gloomy and Sombra appearance
and demeanor her face is described as
half a blue and half flesh-colored there
are even historians who refer to her as
the half goddess in the prose Adder she
is described as ruling over the vast
mansions in hell with many servants
including her loyal Hound garm when we
do see hell's name mentioned it's mostly
done in passing so he never really
develop an idea of her personality other
than being indifferent or disinterested
in the lives of both the living and the
dead the most significant story she
appears in is surrounding the death of
boldir when boldier is slain knowing he
will reside in Hell the I see Ascend and
Emissary to travel to Hell an attempt to
retrieve him the chosen God was baldia's
brother hermod when he arrived in hell
he found his brother and agreed to speak
to Hell herself in the morning hermod
pleaded with hell to free his brother
claiming that every living being shed a
tear for Boulder when he died hell then
set a challenge she would release
Boulder if everything in the universe
shed a tear for him both the living and
dead and so the gods traveled the cosmos
ensuring that everything they came
across shed a tear for Boulder
everything or everyone except for the
yotan or giantesse known as POC who
refused to shed a tear with this one
failure hell deemed the love for Boulder
was untrue and so he would remain in
hell when Loki arrives at the battle
between the gods and the forces of cert
he is accompanied by all of Hell's Souls
so even if hell herself took no part in
this battle all she allowed her father
to borrow the souls of those who had
passed and thus fulfilled the prophecy
of disaster
fenrir is easily identified as the giant
wolf when the three siblings were
separated fenria was the only child the
gods took back to Asgard when feeding
the young pup they noticed him growing
at an abnormal speed and when his growth
continued endlessly the gods began to
worry at this point he had displayed no
evil or cruel Tendencies but he was
still a wolf that would never stop
growing which if left unchecked would
surely lead to the disastrous prophecy
coming true fenrir was prophesized to
kill Odin and his two sons skull and
Hearty were prophesied to swallow the
Sun and the Moon the gods decided for
the safety of everyone the best course
of action was to bind the fenrir they
did this by testing three restraints or
chain means to see which one was able to
hold him in order to test them they had
to lie to fenrir pretending each one was
merely a test of his strength to which
he gladly accepted the challenge each
time fenria Broke Free the gods cheered
telling him that he would be remembered
for his tremendous strength in reality
the gods fears only grew every time he
was able to break free Odin decided it
was time to enlist some help from the
dwarves and so he sent a messenger to
svartelheim here the dwarves used six
mythical ingredients to create a binding
known as glip near a soft silk ribbon
that was deceptively strong examining
the ribbon fenrir was wary he told the
gods after breaking the great iron
chains a mere ribbon would Garner him no
Fame unless it was made to trick him in
which case he refused to be bound the
gods replied if fenrir could not break
such a slender binding then they would
have nothing to fear and he would be
released fenrir agreed but had one
condition he would be bound by the
ribbon if one of the Gods agreed to
place their hand in his mouth as a sign
of good faith the Ico looked around and
no one was willing to volunteer knowing
full well that if they Place their hand
into the wolf's Jaws they would surely
lose it once he was unable to break the
binding only one was brave enough tear
stepped forward and placed his right
hand into the wolf's Jaws the ribbon was
wrapped tightly around fenrir and he
began to struggle even with all his is a
might the ribbon stood firm and their
gods cheered all except tear fenrir
realizing he had been betrayed by the
gods bit down and took tears hand the
gods tied the ribbon to a stone slab and
hammered it deep into the ground they
took a sword and placed it into his
mouth the hilt touching his bottom jaw
and the point of the sword the upper
portion forcing his mouth open so he
could never bite down again fenrir
howled in pain but no one would answer
and there he would remain bound until
Ragnarok when Ragnarok came his sons
skull and Hearty swallowed the Sun and
the Moon the Earth began to shake and
the mountains began to crumble the
bindings holding him snapped and he was
finally able to take revenge on the gods
it says that many men will join the
battle from Valhalla but when the wolf
arrives even their numbers will seem too
little when fenria arrived on the
battlefield he found Odin and after a
crawling encounter he would swallow and
kill the all-father Odin's son vior
would avenge his father's death by
stepping into fenry's Jaws placing one
foot on the lower jaw and holding up the
upper jaw with one hand fenria unable to
bite down was helpless vior then tore
the wolf's jaw apart finally killing
fenrir
the only one of the prophesized children
we've yet to mention is the world
serpent joramanganda who is also known
as the midgard serpent because it was
thrown into the ocean that encircles
mid-guard yodamanganda was a serpent so
big that it could encircle the entirety
of a midgard and place its own tail in
its mouth Jordan Ganda also has several
encounters with the god Thor who he is
prophesized to kill during Ragnarok one
encounter occurs when the Thor goes
fishing with the giant himir as the day
went on Thor wanted a bigger catch each
time and demanded to be taken to the
deepest Waters here he casts the most
sturdy line he has and when a fish bites
to Thor surprise and himir's horror it's
not action actually a fish it's the
world serpent Thor relishes the
opportunity and picks up his hammer
ready to smash the serpent to Pieces him
here on the other hand is absolutely
terrified and with good reason as it
stated when the world serpent removes
its tail from its mouth it is a sign of
Ragnarok him here not too keen on the
end of the world decides to cut the line
and the world serpent sinks to the
bottom of the ocean arguably the first
encounter between the two was the one
that started this entire rivalry in the
story of up guard Loki when Thor and his
group of adventurers encounter the giant
king utgaard Loki he has them perform a
number of challenges when it comes to
Thor he questions his strength he
challenges him to lift a giant cat above
his head this cat however was your
minganda Enchanted and disguised as a
giant cat thaw does managed to lift the
cat however only one of its paws leaves
the ground and thus he has failed later
on in the story utgod Loki confesses to
Thor that he tricked him his attempt at
lifting the cat was more impressive than
he knew as the cat was the world serpent
in Disguise Thor takes this personally
and Val's revenge on the world serpent
for the humiliation he suffered hence
the eagerness to kill him when fishing
the last time Thor meets jorminganda is
during Ragnarok where jorman Gander
emerges from the ocean spraying poison
and everything in his way Thor does
eventually kill the serpent but before
he can walk away he said comes to the
poison and also dies
the last and undoubtedly the weirdest of
Loki's children is slip near the
eight-legged horse and the weirdest part
isn't even the horse with eight legs
it's the circumstances surrounding his
birth in this instance Loki is actually
not the father he's the mother the
father is the Steed svada lafari and
Loki is the mother because at the time
he transformed into a horse and gave
birth a slip near himself to protect
from the yotna the gods hired a builder
to construct a wall to keep the Invaders
away the Builder had approached them
asking for the goddess Freya the Sun and
the Moon in exchange for his services so
not a particularly demanding fellow or
anything after some discussion they
agreed to this deal with some additional
restrictions the Builder was to complete
the work by himself and do so within
three seasons he was only allowed
assistance from his stallion svadolfari
who would carry the huge Stones needed
to build the wall the Builder progressed
much faster than the gods anticipated
the three seasons they had given him was
because they deemed it to be an
insufficient amount of time and
therefore he would break the agreement
and forfeit his right to the goddess
Freya Loki had managed to convince them
that the horse would make no difference
now merely three days away from the
deadline the wall was almost complete
and so the gods turned the blame towards
Loki he was told that he either found a
way to sabotage the Builder or he would
die a horrible death and so Loki vowed
to do whatever it took to rectify the
situation during the night when the
Builder and his stallion did most of the
heavy lifting they came across a mare
the stallion began to chase the mayor
into the woods and left the Builder with
a heap of stone he could not move this
mare was low-key in Disguise and after a
night of being chased around the
stallion eventually caught him and they
mated Loki gave birth to an eight-legged
horse that would be known as slip near
the fastest of all horses and the chosen
Mount of Odin the gods soon realized
that this mysterious Builder was a yotan
and so Thor was summoned to smash his
head to Pieces Loki had played his part
and done everything in his control to
stop the Builder and was forgiven by the
Gods on this occasion
Loki's children are an interesting
cautionary tale they may have been
monstrous in appearance however there is
an argument to be made that they became
monsters because of how they were
treated by Odin and the icir a
self-fulfilling prophecy that leaves us
pondering what could have happened if
they were just left to their own devices
I guess we'll never truly know
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]